darf ich vorstellen das ist dein nachbar
er ist zwar ein netter typ hat aber ein
paar seltsame überzeugungen zum beispiel
die hier
er glaubt zwischen der erde und der
planeten mars kreise eine teekanne um
die sonne
bisher hat noch niemand diese teekanne
gesehen denn sie ist zu klein als dass
sie durch ein teleskop beobachtet werden
könnte dein nachbar nennen wir ihn einen
testen behauptet jedoch solange niemand
meine annahme widerlegen kann bleibe ich
bei meinem glauben was nicht widerlegt
ist daran darf geglaubt werden
doch stimmt das fakt ist es gibt
unzählige bizarre hypothesen die nicht
widerlegbar sind wie etwa die annahme
dass unsere welt von einem fliegenden
spaghettimonster geschaffen wurde
oder dass überall kleine rosa elefanten
sitzen die sich in luft auflösen sobald
wir hinschauen
diese annahmen lassen sich nicht
widerlegen
aber wer glaubt dass etwas existiert
braucht dafür gute gründe dass man es
nicht widerlegen kann allein reicht
nicht
sonst werden beliebig viele absurde
annahmen möglich aber was bedeutet das
für unsere nachbarn unsere t kann
wer hat die richtige einstellung der
teer ist der an die existenz der
teekanne glaube der atheist der an ihre
nichtexistenz glaubt oder der skeptiker
der weder an ihrer existenz noch an
ihrer nichtexistenz glaubt sondern meint
man wisse es eben nicht
und wie steht es um den glauben an die
existenz gottes ist er etwa so
irrational wie der glaube an ein
fliegendes spaghettimonster macht es
sinn an etwas zu glauben dessen existenz
sich nicht belegen lässt